foreign
my perspective which I've summarized in
a book called the corruption of
capitalism
is essentially that the neoliberal
economics Revolution that is associated
with Reagan and Thatcher that began in
the 1980s
which was around the rhetoric of free
markets and around the rhetoric of
individualism and competition
has ended up creating the most unfree
market economy that has ever existed
and it really deserves to be called
rentier capitalism
because what has been happening is that
more and more of the income has flowed
to the owners of property
Financial property physical property and
intellectual property and less and less
has been going to those who perform
labor
so that the functional distribution of
income is the term that we economists
use has become more and more unequal and
this is a global phenomenon associated
with global rentier capitalism the share
going to Capital has gone up share going
to label has gone down but the share
going to the renties
through gaining extras has gone up even
more
and what happened in the 1990s was that
the international architecture of
rentier capitalism was constructed and
the single most influential
piece of legislation
is a piece of legislation called trips
trade related aspects of intellectual
property and what that did was globalize
the American intellectual property
rights system and it was led by the
chief executive of Pfizer you may have
heard of Pfizer and that guarantees
Monopoly profits to the owners of
patents
so now every year more than 3 million
patents are filed and each and every
patent guarantees the owner of the
patent a monopoly profit for 20 years
and with Pharmaceuticals it can be
extended for another 20 years and so
billions and billions of dollars are
going to the owners of intellectual
property that's the first thing the
second thing is that rent has not gone
just to the top one percent of the top
0.1 percent that's journalistic
Simplicity in fact about a quarter of
the population the top two deciles of
the income distribution have done very
well out of rentier capitalism their
property values their shares and so on
have gone up enormously the third point
I want to make is that what happened in
the 1980s and 1990s was that they opened
the door to Domination by Finance
Financial Capital has become the
tail that is wagging the dog
basically big Finance
schools apprentices people who become
politicians and then those politicians
go back and work in big finance and it's
really Goldman sachsism
so Rishi sunak for example spends four
years being trained by Goldman Sachs
then when he becomes Chancellor he
brings in Goldman Sachs people as
advisors the governor of the bank of
England Goldman Sachs trained the
governor of the European Central Bank
Goldman Sachs train you go on and on and
on about the revolving doors between
finance and politics
now give you a couple of stylized facts
about Britain today
because of this comp this composition of
type of capitalism Financial assets of
financial institutions in this country
come to over one thousand percent of our
national income
one thousand percent okay
and
while income inequality has increased
dramatically in that period
while we've had slow growth and lower
taxes coincidentally
wealth has risen to relative to income
so wealth in this country used to be
about 300 percent of national income now
it's over 700 percent
and wealth inequality is much greater
than income and inequality but wealth is
hardly taxed wealth is hardly taxed at
all
and yet over 60 percent of total wealth
in this country is inherited wealth so
you cannot say it was earned or the
dismerited it's inherited
so you have that situation now the
awkward problem for those who say cut
tax them will get growth is they've cut
taxes for the last 40 50 years
and this is the period of slowest growth
in our history
so how long do these low-tax regimes
have to last before they get this
magical growth the last point I want to
make is don't make a fetish of growth
growth of what growth of GDP
the work that more people do than any
other form of work
that has more value than any work I know
is not counted in growth
it's not counted in GDP
and that's care work
by women
how ridiculous why do we want to
increase growth if it means less care
I leave that as my final question but I
do think we have to rethink fiscal
policy rethink how we want to organize
our lives and this is a crisis moment
where we're going to see millions and
millions of people outside Banks hygiene
Banks
suicidal relying on Universal Credit the
worst social policy we've ever had
it's a real crisis moment thank you
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas